une opposition tendues entre éleveurs
locaux et défenseurs de la cause animale
devant l'abattoir à rendeux ou dans près
de 200 agriculteurs se sont rassemblés
pour soutenir l'établissement de la
filière agroalimentaire et défendre leur
volonté de manger de la viande
c'est un acharnement contre tous les
abattoirs contre tous les éleveurs parce
que là ici ils font travailler des
éleveurs moi je suis que céréaliers je
vends mes céréales à des éleveurs donc
si demain on attaque les abattoirs on
attaque les éleveurs et on attaque les
sérails c'est une entreprise familiale
un gros alimentaires et qui en a de
moins en moins en france et puis qu'il
faut les soutenir
qui a aussi une centaine d'emplois
autour de houdan qu'il faut préserver
vue en ce moment le contexte économique
de la france
je suis ici pour deux raisons enfin pour
la raison essentielle qui est de
soutenir les agriculteurs et la filière
des filières des abattoirs tout en
disant fermement que je ne cautionne pas
ce que j'ai vu sur les vidéos c'est à
dire la maltraitance évidente et qu'il
faut y mettre fin d'une manière ou d'une
autre
de l'autre côté une centaine de
militants engagés dans la cause animale
ils disent vouloir se recueillir pour
les victimes de cet abattoir trouve
vraiment lamentable de maltraiter les
animaux dans les abattoirs la souffrance
animale
enfin de cette chaîne de production de
l'alliance est quelque chose qui n'est
plus acceptable
dépôt de gerbes de panneaux et de
bougies les défenseurs de la cause
animale sont restés sur les lieux jusque
tard dans la nuit